hallo eine Freundin hat ihre Tage okay
gut
hallo hallo
keine Ahnung ja wir haben Glashaus sitzt
darf nicht mit nein
ich weiß warum
Junge mit wem willst du telefonieren
weggedrückt Angela Merkel bist du also
guten Tag und guten Nachmittag guten
Abend guten Morgen ja Luca und ich
wollten Lava Video hochladen weil
eigentlich wollte ich heute ein ganz
anderes Video hochladen aber das hat
noch nicht gerade eine Stunde lang uns
gegenseitig in Sims erstellt haben und
die übelste lachkicks geschoben haben
wir jetzt keine Zeit mehr für normales
Video deswegen habe ich gesagt wir
setzen
ich habe mir gedacht wir machen heute
auf jeden Fall mal wieder ein Video wo
wir einfach quatschen äh ihr seht schon
im Titel gar nichts weil es tatsächlich
um gar nichts geht heute dieses Video
gibt absolut keinen Sinn
aber wir wollten euch einfach mal wieder
ja
ja Luca nicht machen übrigens gleich
auch ein Roadtrip in die Heimat Roadtrip
ist eine Stunde
musik Lieder anmachen weil das immer
wieder schrecklich ändert nein nein nein
nein nein ich darf ein Song ein Song
miteinander kam auch einfach an meinte
so darf ich eine Rucksack zumindest bei
du kannst alles mitnehmen hä ja ich will
mit dem Auto umgezogen
zwei Sitzer weil
genau
im Auto und dann ist sie so ich habe ein
Lied das ist neu das ist richtig gut und
dann ist das Lied so ein halbes Jahr
schon draußen oder hat schon so
durchgehört
luca ist momentan in so einer richtigen
ghetto-phase was so ja Motivation so
richtige so so als ob du so Box Musik
und so machst
ich hör total gerne happy Songs happy
Songs was dein Lieblingslied aktuell
boah ich habe viele also ihr wisst ja
schon Sex war ja ultra lang und mein
Lieblingssong aber selbst ich kann es
nicht mehr hören was total schade finde
übrigens äh letztens war nie mehr auch
bei uns in der City am Flughafen
warum war der da keine Ahnung wir haben
jetzt einen neuen Club auch wir haben
jetzt einen neuen Club im Dorf
mir alles geliehen
über quasi und ähm das ist echt krass
wir werden noch zur richtigen Metropole
nein
und Ausweise werden nicht gefälscht so
wie ich es damals gemacht habe
und ja die
spose nein das lohnt sich doch gar nicht
vielleicht macht das auf dem Weg und die
woanders ja aber anders entgegen oder
sowas 20 Minuten Top 5 Songs zu Hause
und dann noch mal hey
Leute aber vielleicht waren die von in
Köln hat einen Gig und dann den nächsten
Gegner in Hamburg und sind dann über
Bielefeld zu mäßig Gefahren genau und
dann fahren die ganz spontan in diesen
Minigolf aber die Kleider die planen das
ja oder planen die okay wenn der geht da
zu Ende ist und der nächste starte da
dann fahren wir auf dem Weg und dann
buchen wir dann im Club und dann kriegen
vielleicht ein kurzerhand für 20.000
kriegen dafür nein doch nicht für 20
Minuten der ganze Laden kostet irgendwas
20.000
hallo ich bin gerade hier am Livestream
okay
ja und ja das war der montanablack
weggedrückt nee ich wollte doch sagen
ich hatte letzte Woche übelst Magen-Darm
ich bin aufgestanden
Donnerstag ging es mir noch ganz gut
damit die Freitag aufgestanden und um 6
Uhr morgens und ich habe schon hattest
du schon mal Magen-Darm
Luca jetzt sucht nicht den Bus hattest
du schon mal Magen-Darm ja oder nein ich
hatte noch nie ich habe noch nie gekotzt
außer von Alkohol sonst habe ich noch
nie gekotzt Alter gott hat dich gegnadet
mich nicht ich bekomme diese Scheiße
nämlich jedes Jahr du bist doch einmal
kurz dann gleichzeitig ja ich habe
nämlich Durchfall und
kocerit ist gleichzeitig ich weiß noch
ich hatte letztes Jahr Magen-Darm habe
ich heute auf Facebook angerufen weißt
du noch doch da haben wir mit unserer
ganzen Gruppe gefesselt wo ich meine ey
muss jetzt kotzen ah stimmt und was auf
dem Klo bei deinen Eltern war das ne und
ich bekomme es jedes Jahr und jetzt hat
sie mich natürlich wieder im schönen
Oktober getroffen oder ist noch
september
nein ist schon Oktober ja hat es mich
getroffen bin aufgestanden mit ultra
fetten Magenschmerzen September ja
wahnsinnig Monate gehen aus wir haben
schon November Luca als Baum gefallen
oder was nächste Woche schon Ende
November Ende Oktober
ja ich wollte noch mal meine Story
zeigen ja ganz genau dann stehe ich auf
was ich bin gespannt dann stehe ich auf
Flitzebogen und ey bei mir ist ja zum
Glück die Toilette ist hier und daneben
ist die Badewanne dann habe ich in die
Badewanne gekotzt und auf Toilette
geschissen ja habe ich gemacht Alter
habe ich einfach mal spontan in die
Badewanne gekotzt
hallo
anrufen wenn du Lust hast oder so okay
haben wir alles geklärt besser ist das
ich schalte mal die Leitung um ne
[Applaus]
wegen Narkose morgen geht auch ja morgen
geht auch ich ja ich komme heute bei so
ich gehe auch gerne mit in den OP rein
alles klar ja ich schenke ihm ruhig ein
halbes Ei ja ja
OP ist die Abkürzung für Operation
Operation ich dachte das wäre irgendwas
Komisches und würde irgendwie verstehen
[Musik]
kannst du mich abholen der Sander macht
tatsächlich bei dem Führerschein was
noch so passiert wir waren heute
zusammen was essen haben wir wieder viel
zu viel bestellt die Hälfte mitgenommen
ah du scheiße da steht auch oben mit der
Mayonnaise die ganze Zeit auf der Küche
oder Sonne gut das können wir glaube ich
nicht mehr essen ja essen wir in deinem
Auto genau ja sonst machen sie noch
nicht dann gleich den Roadtrip äh wir
hoffen euch hat das Video gefallen wenn
es euch gefällt wie Sandra und ich uns
unterhalten dann hört Euch gerne die
neue Podcast Folge an die ist nämlich
jetzt online dann und ich haben in der
letzten Woche Jerry Fraggles zu Gast
gehabt haben und reden in der Folge
jetzt online gegangen ist darüber wieder
alles so war weil das ein bisschen
Wellen geschlagen hat was er dazu
erzählt hat wir haben uns über das
Luciano Konzert unterhalten wo du warst
wir haben uns darüber unterhalten wie
ich vier Mal an einem Abend gekotzt habe
in unserem unterhalten die Sandra in
Paris war drei Nächte aber nur zwei Tage
komischerweise
also hört euch die neue Folge an und ja
wir sehen uns in alter Frische
übermorgen wieder ne
oder lädst du jeden Tag Video hoch oder
übermorgen kommt ein neues Video
Minecraft Video glaube ich
Minecraft Spongebob ja sondern zum Ende
3 2 1